madame Schiappa ce n'est pas tant une
question que je veux poser à cet instant
c'est une supplication que je formule
démissionner
démissionner séance tenante
permettez-nous de croire un instant que
le mot de responsabilité peut avoir du
sens pour un membre du gouvernement la
création et l'attribution de l'argent du
fond Marianne sont d'ores et déjà une
immense tâche que seul votre démission
peut laver quelle que soit l'hypothèse
retenue que vous ayez fait preuve de
légèreté d'incompétence ou d'un cynisme
révoltant pour répondre politiquement de
vos actes il faut démissionner et si
vous vous obstinez la première ministre
doit vous congédier
le scandale du fond Marianne est
proprement inouïe et intolérable dans un
régime démocratique vous avez permis et
peut-être même organisé
l'instrumentalisation de l'assassinat
ignoble de Samuel Paty
ce crime abominable qui voulait mettre à
l'épreuve l'unité de notre peuple vous
l'avez utilisé pour cibler des
adversaires politiques pour détourner
des moyens de l'État au service d'une
campagne électorale et pour ce type
endier de prétendus experts de la lutte
contre l'islamisme tout confirme ses
faits les auditions publiques de la
commission d'enquête au Sénat le rapport
de l'inspection de l'administration et
la démission de Monsieur Gravel l'homme
liche de Monsieur Valls à qui vous aviez
confié comme une récompense le soin de
lutter contre la radicalisation tout est
lamentable dans ce scandale y compris la
tentative de diversion impudante que
vous avez organisé en posant pour un
magazine de charme comment la honte ne
vous a-t-elle pas enseveli comment
soutenez-vous encore le regard de vos
pères du gouvernement et de la
représentation nationale je vous en
adjure madame Schiappa démissionné
la parole
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Sonia bac S ministre chargé de la
citoyenneté
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés et Monsieur le
Député Saintoul visiblement vous ignorez
ce qu'est l'État de droit dans un état
de droit c'est la justice qui juge ce
n'est ni le tribunal populaire ni les
députés
et la justice et la justice vous le
savez tous la justice a pris en main ce
dossier et la l'île du gouvernement a
été claire depuis le début transparence
et réactivité avec Gérald Darmanin nous
avons saisi des connaissances des
premières alertes sur le sujet
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît nous
avons saisi avec Gérald Darmanin dès les
premières alertes sur ce sujet
l'inspection générale de
l'administration et la procureur de la
République de Paris sur le fondement de
l'article 40 le premier rapport de l'IGA
qui a été rendu public mais en évidence
des erreurs voire même des fautes sur le
suivi administratif de ce dossier
l'enquête judiciaire est ouverte il ne
nous appartient pas et il ne vous
appartient pas de la commenter mais
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés et
Monsieur le Député saint Toul nous ne
sommes dupe de rien certains ici veulent
se réjouissent de cette affaire qu'ils
instrumentalisent à souhait dont vous
êtes pour mettre à terre l'esprit de
cette initiative lancé après le terrible
attentat de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine qui
nous a tous terriblement choqué
en salissant l'action engagée de Marlène
Schiappa sur le sujet vous aimeriez
au-delà du fond Marianne mettre un terme
à la politique publique de contredis
pour de contre discours républicains de
lutte contre les séparatistes
qui est mené par l'État depuis les
vagues d'attentats qui ont meurtri notre
pays en matière d'Islam radicale les
discours les plus violents les plus
dangereux ne sont plus dans les mosquées
ils sont sur les réseaux sociaux et je
veux saluer l'action du secrétariat
général du cipdr qui tous les jours
combats ses menaces au service de la
France je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre